they're there
they're there
okay uh
here is uh i'm gonna play one shot
from uh this weekend aaron had posted
this video
uh putin's i said putin's grip is tight
on donald trump
listen to what this [ __ ] fascist says
listen to what he says we will pass
critical reforms making every executive
branch employee fireable
fireable by the president of the united
states the deep state must and will be
brought to heal it's already happening
we will pass critical re okay
so first off here
i'm not exactly opposed to this
i'm not exactly opposed to joe biden
being able to fire
uh louis de joy are you i mean i i
honestly
i think that check and balance can go
[ __ ] that check and balance
but honestly this is coming this is
coming from a position
of a putin-style dictorial ship
right dictatorship sorry
he wants to be kim jong-un he wants to
be vladimir putin vladimir putin bans
the word war
kim jong-un murders and kills any
dissident so does putin
and that's what he means he doesn't
actually mean oh i want to fire him
they don't actually mean i just want to
stop a woman from having abortion
what they mean is i want to get rid of
that person
i don't want to stop someone from being
gay i don't want to stop someone from
being trans i want to get rid of their
existence are you listening
this is what fascism
does
it is on our front doorstep
we shall not let it go through the back
door
we have to call this out we have to show
this for what it is all america needs to
know what the because all americans
aren't watching this [ __ ]
they're not listening to the voices that
need to be listened to jesus christ the
entire world burnt down when tom brady
retired and the entire world burnt down
again when he said i'm not retiring
that was the [ __ ] news
every american knows that news
no one knows that the former president
united states not only is his company
his private [ __ ] company is under
criminal and civil indictment
members members of his [ __ ] cabinet
are under investigation members
members of the group that is one step
away from him have pled guilty
to conspiracy to sedition an oath keeper
who was roger stone's private bodyguard
on january 6 when he tried to take over
the government and attempt a cheeto dust
kangaroo goo
one step away you don't think roger
stone was on the phone with donald trump
you don't think roger stone is one step
away from the cheeto dust mobster
but america doesn't know
america has no idea that he stole
classified documents
america has no idea that he was putting
doc
top secret documents in burn bags and
flushing them down the toilet
eating our he was eating are you
listening he was eating
our [ __ ] records of the office of the
president of the united states our the
american people those are our records he
was eating them like they were [ __ ] a
big mac
because he needed to hide what they said
yep
america doesn't know yet
we have to show them
we have to tell them
we have to tell everyone around us
at your family barbecue at your
community center your churches your
schools in the [ __ ] grocery line with
the checkout person
stop talking about tom brady who gives a
[ __ ]
who gives a [ __ ]
who gives a [ __ ] if that guy plays
football or not not going to make one
hell of a bit of a difference in our
democracy and frankly
frankly
tom brady with his white pasty ass will
be one of the only quarterbacks to be
able to throw a ball once fascism takes
over
mark my word